What I thought I
would attempt to do
in this and the next
few videos is just give
a scaffold of American history.
I'm clearly going to glaze
over a lot of the details,
but hopefully it'll
give you a sense
of how everything at
least fits together,
at least the major events
in American history.
So you can kind of, and
when I say American history,
I'm talking about
United States history.
And so the first real
successful settlement
in what's now the United
States was at Jamestown.
That's Jamestown,
Virginia right over here.
And it was 1607.
It was set up as kind of
a commercial settlement
and then shortly after
that, and we always
learned this in school, you know
the pilgrims on the Mayflower,
sailing the oceans
blue and all the rest.
They were kind of the next major
settlement in the New World.
Or I guess we should say the
next major successful English
settlement.
There were obviously the Spanish
and the Portuguese were already
settling the New World
with a good bit of success
at this point, but we're talking
about the English settlements.
And so the pilgrims
settled what's
now Plymouth,
Massachusetts in 1620.
And obviously from 1620
until the mid-1700s,
you just had a huge influx of
people migrating and cities
developing.
But I'm going to fast forward
all the way to the mid-1700s.
So this is actually
a huge amount of time
that I'm just not
providing any details over.
Because I'm really just quite
focused on the major events
in American history.
And so this is a 130-year
period where things were just
getting built out more, they
were getting more developed.
And I'm going to fast
forward to 1754, because
at this period you
had essentially
the entire east coast
of what's now the US.
These were the 13
colonies of the-- well,
they're not the
United States yet,
they're the 13 British colonies.
But these are
English settlements,
and then if you go a little bit
to the northwest from there,
you have all the
French settlements.
And obviously still in these
parts of Quebec and Canada,
people speak French.
But you had the
French settlements
up in this area over here.
I'm not going to go
into the details.
Each of these can be a
whole series of videos,
and hopefully in
the future I will
make them whole
series of videos.
But you fast forward
to 1754, and you
start having the French
and the British start
getting into squabbles
over territory
where Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania is right now.
In 1754.
And that starts the
French and Indian War.
And I want to be very clear
here because this is maybe
one of the biggest
points of confusion
when people first
learn American history.
Since it's called the
French and Indian War,
they think it's between
the French and the Indians.
But it's not.
It was the French
and the Indians
against the British
and the colonists.
So in this war, the
British and the colonists
were on the same side against
the French and the Indians.
And obviously there
were some Indians
that were also on the
side of the British,
but it's called the French
and Indian War because these
were the people that the
British were fighting against.
Now if anyone outside
of the United States
talks about the
French and Indian War,
they will not call it the
French and Indian War.
They'll really just call
that the American theater
of the Seven Years' War
because it eventually
evolves into a much bigger
conflict between Great Britain
and France that's
going on in Europe,
and the French and
Indian War was really
just the American theater of it.
So between-- the
French and Indian
War starts in 1754 based on
these disputes over Pittsburgh.
But that wasn't the only thing.
You had all of these
other things, all
of these other tensions
that were developing.
The thing that starts the
war is never the only factor.
It's always just
the tipping point.
But that leads to a
bigger war in Europe.
And that's the Seven Years'
War that starts in 1756.
And they both end because
they're really the same war.
They both end in 1763
with the Treaty of Paris.
Treaty of Paris, 1763.
And the big takeaway of that is
that really most of what France
had in the New World
now becomes essentially
a part of the
British Empire, now
becomes British colonies
or British territories.
And even Louisiana goes
over to Spain at this point.
And we'll see it
goes back to France
for a little bit
in 1800, and then
it goes back to the
United States in 1803,
but we'll see that in a second.
So 1763, the British-- it
was this huge costly war--
but they were able to win.
And at least from the point
of view of the British,
they felt that the main
beneficiaries of this war
were the Americans.
They were able to get all
this new territory, all
this new area that they
can now trade with,
or they could now
potentially settle.
And so the British
decide to start
taxing the Americans
to recoup some portion
of the cost of the war.
So in 1765 they
pass the Stamp Act.
And this wasn't a tax on stamps.
What this was is
that they essentially
declared that a
whole set of paper
that had to be used
in the New World.
So the stuff for
legal documents,
stuff that maybe even newspaper.
That that paper would have to
be produced in Great Britain,
and it had to have a
special stamp on it in order
for the contracts or
whatever was on top of it,
in order for them
to be legitimate.
So essentially it was a huge
tax on paper and on documents.
And essentially, this is
what societies ran on.
So it was just a way to extract
money from the colonists
in order to, I guess, help
pay back some of the costs
that the empire felt
that they had incurred
on behalf of the colonists.
You could debate whether who
was the main beneficiary, but
regardless you could
imagine this didn't make--
this whole period over here--
the colonists weren't happy.
Especially because
they didn't have
any representation
in Parliament.
This was done without
anybody from the colony
saying, hey, wait I
don't think that's fair.
Or this is fair or whatever.
And so you fast forward.
1773, you have the
Boston Tea Party
where you have a bunch of
people who, for whatever reason,
and there's multiple
interests here.
But there was three ships
in Boston Harbor full of tea
and the tea was owned by
the East India Tea company.
And they decide, in
protest, and there
was a whole series of
acts and other taxes
that went back and forth,
but once again, we're
not going to go into
the details here.
But in revolt they
dumped the tea.
They dressed up as Indians,
as American Indians,
and they dumped the
tea into Boston Harbor,
and then you could
imagine well that was
kind of a very exciting
act for the colonists,
but it didn't make the
British very happy.
And then after that, they
passed the Coercive Act.
They essentially did
a blockade of Boston.
So things started to
get really, really,
really tense in the early 1770s.
And then you fast
forward to 1775,
you have essentially the first
conflicts of the American
Revolutionary War,
and we're going
to do a whole series
of videos on really
the whole Revolutionary War.
1776, you have the
Declaration of Independence.
This is them right here
drafting the Declaration
of Independence.
And that's really just
saying, hey, we've
had enough of you Great Britain!
We are now declaring ourselves
as an independent country.
No more of this
colonies business.
And so all the
way until 1783 you
have the American
Revolutionary War.
And once again, you can do
a lot of videos on this,
but I'm just going
to go over it just
so you have a sense of
when everything happened
and when everything ended.
And we can later dig
deeper into the scaffold.
And it ends with
the Treaty of Paris.
The US becomes a free
independent state.
And then you fast forward.
Until this point,
the US has been
governed by Congress, and the
Articles of Confederation.
But the Constitution
that we have now,
it was drafted in 1787.
It was ratified-- it had to
get at least nine of the states
to ratify it-- that
happened in 1788.
And then it went
into effect in 1789.
So it depends what you consider
the birth of the country.
Well, it would definitely be
the Declaration of Independence,
but the country in
its current form,
with its current institutions,
with this current constitution,
started in 1789.
And that was also the
beginning of Washington's first
of two terms as president,
and those ended in 1797.
And then John Adams
comes into the picture.
And the reason why I
put this-- obviously
this is actually the only
president that I showed--
is that it was
actually very important
that he decided to step
down after two terms.
He was hugely popular.
If he wanted to,
he probably could
have become one of
these characters that
stick around maybe
a little bit longer
than some people would want.
So it was really good that he
set this example of stepping
down after two
terms, and that he
wasn't this kind of
power hungry dude.
You fast forward
a little bit more.
1803, I mentioned that after
the French and Indian War what's
Louisiana-- I want to be
clear when I say Louisiana.
Louisiana isn't just what's
the current state of Louisiana.
It's this whole
region that includes
the state of Louisiana,
but all the way up
to roughly what
the United States'
current border with Canada.
And after the French
and Indian War,
all of this business
over here went to Spain.
And then in 1800, it
went back to France.
But then in 1803, Napoleon
had a bunch of stuff
that he-- his Naval
fleet was destroyed,
he had a suffered some
defeats in the West Indies,
I guess we could call it.
In particular in
Haiti, and he said,
well, you know I
probably won't be
able to control this
territory anyway,
so he sold it to
the United States
for what turned out to be a
very, very, very cheap price.
But it was kind
of like, it's not
like he could have
protected it anyway.
The United States
might have been
able to take it from him without
him being able to do anything.
So he might as well
get some money for it
so that he could fund
his battles in Europe.
So in 1803, the United States
almost doubled in size.
It went from these
territories that it
had after the American
Revolution for Independence,
and now it got all of this
region over here in 1803.
Then you fast forward a bit.
And the War of 1812,
it's an interesting one,
because there weren't any
really serious outcomes from it.
But what was interesting about
it, this whole time period,
even after independence,
the British
continued to harass America.
They continued to arm Native
Americans who would maybe
revolt or cause
trouble for settlers.
They would impress
American seamen--
and when I say
impress, it didn't
mean that they were
doing something special.
It meant that they
were-- impressment
of seamen meant that they
were taking over these boats,
taking the sailors,
and forcing them
to become part of
the British military.
So they were doing
a whole series
of things that was really kind
of antagonizing the United
States.
In 1812, the United States
declares war on Great Britain.
You have the War of 1812.
It ends in 1815 with the
Battle of New Orleans.
But there wasn't
any real transfer
of a territory or anything
like that over here.
What was good, some people call
it the Second War for American
Independence, is it really
asserted that America was here
to stay, or I should say that
the United States was here
to stay.
That the Revolution wasn't
just some fluke that isn't some
just fly by night country.
It was able to defeat one of the
greatest empires in the world
again.
So it's kind of here to stay.
Now you fast forward
a little bit more.
This part of what
we would call Texas,
this area right over here.
It was, before 1836,
it was part of Mexico.
But the Mexicans
actually encouraged
English-speaking
settlers-- these
would be American
English-speaking settlers
into the area-- just because
it was very sparsely settled.
But these English-speaking
settlers, a lot of them
were slave owners, and then
as we kind of go up to 1836,
the state of Mexico that
this was all governed by,
they were thinking about
abolishing slavery.
So you can imagine that
the settlers there, they
didn't like this idea.
So in 1836, you had the
War for Texas Independence,
and that's where you remember
the Alamo, and all of that.
And then the first president
of Texas is Sam Houston.
That's why Houston
is named Houston.
And then you fast forward
all the way to 1845.
And in this time period,
you have this whole talk
in the United States
of Manifest Destiny,
that it's part of our
God-given destiny as Americans,
to one day extend our territory
all the way to the Pacific
Ocean.
So people were already eyeing
a lot of the territory.
Remember all of this
territory, this was Texas.
And Mexico still viewed
it as their territory,
even though it was being
governed independently
by the people who
called themselves
the Republic of Texas.
And you had all
of this territory
that was Mexican territory.
So people were starting
to eye this and say,
wouldn't it be nice to
get a little bit of that?
So in 1845, and this
was in agreement
with the settlers in Texas,
with the Republic of Texas,
the United States annexed Texas.
The settlers there
wanted this to happen,
so wasn't a forced
annexation of Texas.
But Mexico was not
so happy about this
because Mexico
still viewed Texas
as part of their territory.
And America, to some degree,
depends on how you view it,
it seems like they kind of
wanted to goad Mexico into war,
so they sent military really
close to the border of Mexico,
even into some territory where
Mexico might have had better
claims to it or-- I'm not
going to take sides on this,
but it seemed like there was
some instigation going on.
And there's some debate about
the actual course of events.
But in 1846 you have war
actually breaking out
between Mexico and
the United States.
And by 1848, the United States
essentially trounces Mexico,
and most of the war actually
does go on on Mexican land.
And because of that, Mexico
cedes over all of this area.
So, California and all of
the rest of Nevada, Arizona,
what the part of New Mexico
the didn't come along,
that the United States
didn't already have.
And along that same
amount of time,
you both had the British
and the Americans that
were eyeing this territory,
the Oregon Territory up here
and it even included
part of Canada.
And eventually they were
able to resolve it relatively
peacefully, and
what they agreed is,
is that the Americans would
get all of this territory.
And the British would
get everything north
of this line right over here.
And that's why Vancouver
and British Columbia and all
of that, is Canada now.
It stayed as part of the British
Empire for a little bit longer.
So by 1848, the Manifest Destiny
essentially had happened.
The United States had gotten
everything from California
all the way from the Pacific
coast to the Atlantic coast.
And clearly I'm really just
covering the high levels,
30,000 level foot view
of American history here.
This whole time you had
this tension developing.
From the birth of the country
through the election of Abraham
Lincoln, you have this
tension over slavery.
A lot of people in the
North didn't like it
on moral grounds.
A lot of people in the
South didn't like it-- well,
they wanted slavery
regardless of what
they thought of it morally--
the South's economy,
to a large degree,
was based on slavery.
And so all of this, the
tipping point happened in 1860.
Where Abraham Lincoln, who was
pretty vocal about the fact
that he did not like
slavery, that he wanted
to curb the spread
of slave states.
And up to this point, you
had all of these compromises
every time a state
came into the Union.
The slave states wanted it
to be another slave state.
The free states wanted it
to be another free state.
So you always had
this people kind
of jocking for whoever
could have the most
states on their
side of the camp.
But all of this pro-slavery
and anti-slavery
hit a tipping point in 1860
when Abraham Lincoln, who
was fairly vocal about
not extending slavery,
he was elected.
Then a bunch of what we now
consider southern states
seceded from the Union.
And then in 1861
in South Carolina.
South Carolina said, hey, we are
not part of the United States
anymore, but there was still a
United States military garrison
there, so they attacked it.
That started the Civil War.
And so during the Civil War--
it lasts until 1865-- Abraham
Lincoln makes the
Emancipation Proclamation
in 1863, which
essentially proclaims
all the slaves should be free.
This lays the groundwork
for the 13th Amendment
to the Constitution.
And then unfortunately,
he dies two months
before the end of the Civil War.
But in 1865, the South
surrenders and so
they're not able to secede.
And essentially,
we no longer have
slavery in the United States.
So I'm going to leave--
and it's fascinating,
and just to give you a sense
of things, here's the map.
The navy blue are the Union
states, the northern states,
the light blue are the
territory controlled
by the northern states.
This orange color
are the states that
seceded from the
Union, the Confederacy.
And this light orange,
these are territories
that they controlled,
but they were disputed.
These yellow states right here
were members of the Union.
They didn't secede
from the Union.
They didn't join
the Confederacy,
but they were slave states.
But probably the most
fascinating thing
about the Civil War,
other than the fact
that it ended slavery
in the United States,
that was probably
its biggest thing,
but it was also
the bloodiest war
that ever happened in the
United States history.
During the Civil War-- and
these are unbelievable numbers--
18% of white males
in the South died.
18%, almost one out of every
five white males in the South,
died during the Civil War.
And for the North, it
was slightly better.
It was 6%.
But still, a huge percentage
of the men in the United States
died fighting the Civil War.